i didn't want to open a restaurant i
don't like restaurants i think
restaurants are cold and robotic and
they don't feel comfortable and i wanted
a place that feels
like you're just in my house so i
designed it to feel like my house
i'm flynn mcgarry
and i'm the chef of gem
new york the restaurant is called gem
which is my mom's name backwards it was
also her idea
i started by doing these dinners in my
mom's house so sort of an homage to what
those dinners felt like and were but
also
were sort of hidden behind these trees
on the little
street that like you would walk down you
could walk right by and not even know we
were here i started uh cooking again
when i was 10 i think probably the first
memory cooking i actually have was it
was like mother's day i was like oh i'm
gonna make like brunch for everyone and
i made like chicken salad or something
but i was like i'm gonna like poach the
chicken or do something different with
it and it felt very fancy at the time
but then i just sort of became obsessed
with sort of the more kind of intricate
and creative side of cooking when i
started cooking my my mom was like okay
we'll go get you like a cookbook she
took me like burns you know whatever and
i was 10 so i wanted the most expensive
thing that was on the top shelf so i got
the french laundry cookbook and that
just sort of like initially blew my mind
as far as like what cooking was so i
found about elinia because he used to
work at french laundry then i got that
cookbook and love madison park it was
the same thing they love madison park
service internship i met them on their
book signing tour i was talking about
how i had been sort of cooking some
things from the book and they're like oh
do you have any photos of it and i
showed them a bunch of photos of the
stuff that i had cooked
and it
looked surprisingly like like the book
they were like if you ever want to come
sort of hang out in the kitchen in new
york let us know and then like a month
later i made my way here i was free
labor so everyone was down to have it i
mean the general thing with restaurants
at that level is just the
absurd attention to detail with
everything that you learn and that is
something that
kind of
has stayed with me of like everything i
do in every regard this kind of thought
all the way through you're aware yeah
nothing's gonna be perfect but still
having the strive for that
helps you wake up
way too early every day and go to bed
way too late every day the beet dish has
been on the menu for like three years
now
it's the only thing that won't leave it
was sort of inspired by this one a
feeling that i hate beets
and two this sort of want for giving
someone
the most savory
intense course on their menu is a
vegetable trips a lot of people out uh
intentionally
the best dishes are the ones that people
are just like i don't understand what
that was but it was delicious i stopped
going to school actually when i was like
15. i've
had a full-time job since i was 12. i've
never really focused too much on like
being like i need to have like a normal
teenage experience because i'm just
literally never had no desire to do that
my investors and everyone would not be
super happy if i was just like yeah i'm
gonna take some time off the restaurant
to like go play video games like the
issues and stuff that and qualms and
stuff that i deal with are those of
someone who
is definitely not 19. i knew everyone
was always going to talk about my age
and like do i love that not really but
it's something that i always knew i was
gonna have to deal with if i wanted to
do this being young getting sort of
helps you
get a lot of opportunities but then once
you get those people seem to have much
higher expectations for what you can do
than that of a normal person regardless
of their age a big thing for me is sort
of dealing with having to pull back from
the actual cooking myself and focus more
on the bigger picture i'm a control
freak in every regard there's not a
single thing in this restaurant that i
will let
go by without me looking at it it's a
blessing and a curse
[Music]
we didn't want to compromise the
experience and the overall vision that
we have for your dinner by being cheap
or not being not giving you the best
quality of every ingredient and not
being able to hire the right amount of
staff so you feel comfortable we also
have a sense of humor about ourselves
and understand what we do is very
absurdist and
over the top so we like to also have fun
we spend literally 18 hours a day
together six days a week
so i
have to like them so i could not hire
people that i don't like because i would
just hate it for so long this has been
the goal and now that i've kind of
reached this point it's sort of the
restaurant dictates what's next and i'm
just sort of along for the ride i did go
to coachella a couple years ago to cook
but
it was not a fan